okay so this is like every other v-log
we've ever done I couldn't help myself
so we have a couple extra guess I can't
help myself
he is a blanking as named uh Oh Phelan
I'm sorry so we got we got Phelan here
and we also have I guess if you're
failing I'm Lupin ow
I'm bigger and bigger loves comics sub
obscura Spiga that's curious vegan ha ha
ha and fame Cara then so but they were
endowed with the Lewis's in town is
saying like you know I never did it yeah
I've never received adventure time and
you can watches it all the time and said
like to do a V log so we're gonna do
this one called car Wars which is such a
good intro to adventure time because
that's so much what every episode is
like just then sitting around playing
cards it's a perfect introduction so but
you play I know you play like Yugi but
yo yo ya be beginning you gonna for like
five years
tournaments regionals the whole nine
yards okay okay funny thing for me is
especially having watches while being a
big fan of Yugi the abridged series and
of yugioh the anime itself so of course
it's super advanced holic ramps for a
children's card game so and I I never
played any unlike pokers the closest
thing to a card game I played in the
sense and Jason do you ever done a the
card games and I played pretty much all
of them because of my children
okay so man like yugioh Pokemon you name
a card game have pretty much done
because of my kids so so we have got a
wide range of you know people have done
whatever one card games but I mean it
and I'll give the breakdown real fast
like it says called card wards and it's
pretty much just watching Finn and Jake
play this card game it's very much like
yugioh or is it all like pokemons
they're not really
but it's a lot of them have a similar
kind of premise to them which involves
like attacking defending using various
energy or or land cards in CS lanterns
in this case are more akin to what Matt
imagine losing actions and the land
cards are very much magic that's what I
when I saw this that's like the first
thing that popped in my head the overly
complicated rules the amount of like
just stuff that goes into it the turning
of the lands and all that stuff yeah I
took it more as definitely a mocking of
magic so so but you could say it's a
mocking actually okay mocking of the
people who get overly obsessive and
Adams jackass magic is the one most
people think of that service because
it's the one that's been long lasting
and popular
so what's going on the Finn and Jake are
playing this game and they and Jake gets
really into it Finn sword doesn't really
care that much he's kind of doing
beginner's luck and it turns out he's
really good at it Rama days soup I'm
with my new favorite term I love it and
so he gets into a Jake according to BMO
gets really depressed when he loses so
Finn starts to let him win at the end
and then it ends that's not just that
because remember the stakes here are we
have to drink the discussing epic AK
drink yank these super awesome soda it
turns out there to it like but this
stuff doesn't work then faked him so
Jake would have to drink it that's why
when Jake drink oh okay I bang they
drink it anyway because they're good
friends so so yeah I mean very
compared to the other episode not much
really happens in this one but huge card
game fans here so the first episode all
about car Kings what you think of it I
liked it very much I actually did
sympathize a lot with the various
attitudes displayed here Jake said I
don't know her name princess something
or other deploying like lady rings Lady
Rainicorn you just assume it's a
princess cuz like every girl knows what
what I know about adventuretime is
mostly through Colossus and tumblr gifs
and whatnot so I know that there's a
princess like bubblegum or something
right it's a princess everything so of
course that's I don't know their name I
don't know the names of a lot of them
but if you just say princess DVD it's
something that's us right princess yeah
breakfast princess there's a running
joke that there's a princess everything
in this show so it's yeah anyway the
idea is that I understood the attitude
that she apparently had which was I
don't like playing because I always lose
and my brother and I would river play
you yogi used to kick my ass all the
time and eventually it took up a bummer
I don't really want to play anymore cuz
I'm just gonna lose so what's the point
yeah and that's a perv illegitimate as
you to take or you take the other
attitude which is I'm gonna do even
better I'm feel stronger and I'll get
better and now I'm the awesomest best
yugi'll player ever there you go my
argument what that is for me is that
anytime I played one of these card games
and whatnot
yeah of course I'd suck at it or whatnot
because I'd get a starter deck or
something and maybe like an extra pack
or two and these people would be playing
for like two years longer than me and
they'd have like always like extremely
rare cards and it's like in order to get
better for the most part I'm not saying
overall you had to spend a bunch more
money just to get up that level and it's
like I don't want to spend that much
more money to sit there and go haha I
beat you in a game I'd rather play risk
or something or monopoly I knew guys who
would buy a box Oh
the thing is Doug booster packs come in
boxes and I don't care and sometimes
rarer more powerful cards there's only
like one per box if you're even lucky
with that if you're even lucky yeah yeah
sometimes you get a good moment when you
get like a freaking Jinzo all color I
got Jinzo all the damn time five or six
of them I saw was like super rare you
did some yourself you mean you're a
weird cyborg burn victim person
one way of putting it shirt oh but
anyway yeah let's say let's go back to
adventure time yeah this was fun mean it
just shows do got two friends having fun
and playing the game and of course
there's there's a lot you can read into
this just us from that because obviously
Jake is more interested in just kind of
lording over ha I'm so much better than
the other thing where as opposed to just
trying to teach the teach the game and
going easy to begin with and you know
let them build up let them work on it do
better over time and then you can
actually like you know face before he's
just caring about learning it over them
but at the same time then Finn is all
worried about oh if I beat him he's
gonna not be my friend for a while well
what I like about it it's talking to
someone that honestly didn't get super
into this episode I think because I I
don't wake these guy games or whatever
so it's like I want to see them go out
fighting whatever but but the one thing
I found very interesting is that I mean
sure you know they go on a lot of
adventures and stuff like that and
usually people that sort have this
attitude about certain games you know
like well I have to win I have to be in
control of this are people that don't
have a lot going on like this is the
Orang don't have a lot of control their
whole life you know at least you know so
it's like this is the area where they
can really have control really reigned
over and abusive and stuff and they hate
it when they lose their control in their
world
Jake is like he constantly has control
he can turn it to anything he constantly
goes on adventures he's really confident
so I found it really funny that he would
like Nivas control in this game I
thought that was a very fascinating sort
of insight obviously but jake has always
been about himself though that's true I
mean look at everything he kind of does
yeah he does he likes to help people but
a lot of times seems like in the end
he's more or less doing it for himself
or to better his image or like it's fun
for him yeah like and I think the game
is one of those things where he's
awesome at it he can literally rub
everyone's face in it and he doesn't
have to exert himself because that's
another thing
Jake is very lazy yeah that's where he
doesn't have to do anything and he can
still show how awesome he is yeah no
that's true so I get I guess it makes
total sense what about BMO Aires
games with Jake Jake is just like he's
oh oh what how do I say it he's an
a-hole when it comes to Florida and over
Oh everyone know that one guy in the
comic shop that does that with like geek
the trivia or card games or how much
comics I have yeah when I've seen people
that definitely I mean a different card
game but like playing poker and stuff I
mean there have been people that come in
and there aren't like beginners that's
like beginner's luck or they don't know
the rules and they'll get lucky but
eventually people Kelly you know catch
on or shut them down and stuff like that
but there are some that naturally just
kind of pick up really fast all right
know the odds and stuff like that and
there is just this legit anger for
people that like been doing this for
such a long time that when somebody
comes in that's kind of new but legit
legitimately plays it well it's really
frustrating if it's like a new person
because these are people have been
learning the odds and everything have
been playing forever and then to learn
so much and hear someone that just picks
it up right away so but it's also like
if you play against people who are
really serious with poker I don't have a
poker face because every time I get a
card like awesome
it's a terrible card everything don't
care so people like can't read you when
you don't have a poker face because
you're always excited right you're
always having a good time and they're
thrown off by it and people get really
pissed off at just something as simple
as that play the game seriously oh I'm
having a good time
why do I need to be so effing serious -
why I mean I think this place would go
like there's definitely like like I love
playing poker but I would never go to
like let like mike moschetti she loves
playing poker and he'll go to all these
tournaments or something then he'll do
legitimately pretty good but like I
always feel like I'm out of my league if
I do that I don't want to like embarrass
myself and the game and stuff I coming
in like you know but it's like
like I love the game so much I love the
respect other people have for it I don't
like get in the way of that respect it's
not I don't want be the jackass it's
like I mean I always try to keep it to
like you know like hey are we just
playing for fun just for like 20 bucks
or something like that okay let's do
that there's a difference between like
you going in wanting to have a good time
and like having fun with it then what
like Jake did you know that fun with the
game like Finn was having a blast with
the game oh I'm gonna flip the pig Jake
was taking it way too serious yeah
that's the thing if I go to play poker
even it's probably $10,000 if I had
$10,000 why can't I be happy when I play
an act like an idiot if I $10,000 just
on me to play a poker I'd be happy
already
it's a game it doesn't have feelings
people get that up Titan that upset
about it it's like people getting upset
about Adventure Time mmm I I think it's
kind of like doing like whatever just
playing soccer like with your friends
and playing soccer in the Olympics the
Olympics who run and kick a goal they
jump up and down yeah no no I agree I'm
saying like that's why it's like there's
a time in place for all this stuff you
take one to take this like this
seriously and I'm that good you know he
should find other people are playing the
ones make it that seriously but yeah if
he's just like if you say just the lord
over people which it looks like he kind
of was anyway then yeah that's not the
right thing and I think they balance it
out pretty good that know what one last
question before we probably start
wrapping us up here uh do you think it
was right for Finn to let Jake win I'm
just gonna go with yes because having
beaten someone who is like that it's
really obnoxious and annoying because
not only will they be pissed off at you
they'll want to play you again and again
and again until they beat you this I'm
never gonna rub your face in it twice as
much you know what get that loss over
with
so suck it up and be like you know what
it's just not worth it
go ahead take this win lord it over me
that's fine I don't want to hear it
later on
pulse later on you can go you know what
I already lost once I don't feel like
playing again mm with Jake
yeah but whenever someone let me win
because like the way I get when I'm
winning sometimes it's like but no like
I think it's more along the lines of fan
don't let him win it in order to say
that right no not no like Finn let him
win
on purpose but he made it look like it
wasn't on purpose yeah that's what I'm
saying like if you if you're against
someone and you're sneaky enough to make
it where it doesn't look painfully
obvious would you do it
oh look good to make the argument that
that person should learn to lose at some
point or Canales and they reach and you
bring that up and I would say yes was
right but with the caveat that he did
make Jake lose in the end by by making
him do the drink the disgusting drink
the balance so it was kind of eight okay
yeah you got me you're right okay that
serious they're never gonna learn or
it's gonna take a long time to learn
about losing yeah yeah is it even worth
throwing this - what - them would be
like a giant a bomb actually yeah game
you know would that actually be even
worth it or if you're going to do this
or teach them something do it baby steps
you know well think about it he already
lost to BMO and he stopped talking to be
mophir he said well yeah that's true I
probably know maybe he lost a ray Picaro
me though yeah and that's the thing
obviously he hasn't learned about losing
already and it's like oh well is it
really worth it no kid the friendship
intact you already played your one game
he got his little glory out of it
whatever why it shows that Finn's
definitely the bigger person cuz he got
one last thing I wanted to bring up the
very beginning of the episode where the
deep thoughts with Finn sometimes it's
okay to not have anything in the box but
it's also not as necessary of sadness
thing if you have things in the box -
the box so good stuff well I'm gonna
play cards get out the yukiho
come on get out the bigger blind box
I'm lazy no we I have to wait let's talk
about the philosophy of the box you
start i feel the boxes the per board
option